welcome to fast fashion in the 1980s
most fashion lines brought out new
collections two to four times a year
today modern Brands like H&M and Forever
21 release new items every 2 weeks
Americans now buy 68 pieces of clothing
a year five times as much as we did in
1980 manufacturers have cut back on
everything from labor to material to
construction these clothes are literally
made to fall apart many retailers
regularly violate labor laws setting
16-hour work days and paying employees
what amounts to a few cents per garment
it's no good for the environment either
with Americans throwing out 11 million
tons of textiles a year fast fashion now
accounts for 8% of global Greenhouse
emissions what can you do buy fewer
garments ones that are higher quality
and will last longer you won't be at the
Forefront of every fashion trend but
remember those Trends are just invented
by the industry to take your money